you guys want to pull back the curtain a
little bit yes all right take a look at
this story from the new york post no the
judge who okayed the mar-a-lago raid is
an obama donor once linked to jeffrey
epstein what now
i stated this at the end of the show
when i heard the news
i said yeah yeah what does
epstein-linked mean it's like his
brother once catered a restaurant
epstein served internet you know you get
these sensational headlines and then i
read it and it was he was a federal
prosecutor who abruptly switched sides
joining the defense for jeffrey epstein
for his lieutenants not for epstein
specifically and uh
okay that's weird check it out
reinhardt was elevated to magistrate
judge in 2018 after 10 years in private
practice that november the miami herald
reported that he had represented several
of epstein's employees
including by reinhardt's own admission
to the outlet epstein's pilots his
scheduler sarah kellen and nadia
marcinkova who epstein once reportedly
reportedly described as his yugoslavian
sex slave
helen kellen and martin kova were among
epstein's lieutenants who were granted
immunity as part of a controversial 2007
deal with federal prosecutors that
allowed him to plead guilty to state
charges rather than federal crimes
epstein wound up serving just 13 months
in county jail and was granted work
release
that's really really interesting in the
miami herald story they mention
actually look they say um
he donated to barack obama's
presidential campaign months after he
left the local use attorney's office to
rep employees of the convicted peto
jeffrey epstein who had received
immunity in the long-running trafficking
investigation of the financier of
financier
so this guy
was accused many are arguing
i guess his his
side of it was he didn't have any
private information or anything
they say 10 months after starting work
for epstein's co-conspirators according
to the federal election commission
reinhardt gave one thousand dollars
directly to the obama campaign another
thousand dollars to its fundraising arm
the obama victory fund though the
records show the judge made mostly small
dollar donations blah blah i don't know
uh how much i care about the donation
stuff
but i think what's interesting is that
he's basically accused of flipping sides
in a 2013 court filing reinhardt's
former colleagues contradicted him
saying he had learned confidential
non-public public information about the
epstein matter while employed by the u.s
attorney's office
reinhardt noted the herald in response
that a complaint filed against him by a
lawyer for epstein's victims had been
dismissed in a 2011 affidavit reinhardt
denied he had done anything improper and
insisted that since he was not involved
in the federal investigation of epstein
he was not privy to inside information
about the case as recently as january
2015 reinhardt was asked to appear on
newsmax to give analysis on the epstein
fallout but declined to uh to publicly
note his own role in the case
okay
maybe
it's just he's a judge in the area
that's all it is right maybe it's just
one big coincidence
my favorite conspiracy theory right now
donald trump apparently took classified
documents to mar-a-lago
the conspiracy theory is
he took the as he took it as leverage
from his time as president
i mean look people were saying that if
trump lost they would lock him up right
and so now the theory is trump took
leverage
they're trying to get the leverage back
that being said i do believe the simple
solution in the absence of evidence is
simply that trump had a bunch of
staffers grabbing boxes from the white
house when he was leaving some of those
boxes had documents that's about it but
if that's all that it is
like if i if i said this today if i was
on the left right now and if i was a big
you know anti-trump person i would be
furious at the fbi right now i'd be
furious at this judge because if you
shoot the king and miss like your your
whole case is destroyed you just made
the best possible argument for trump
2024 so if it's really just oh well
there's a few boxes that got pulled from
some staffers and ended up in his house
and that was enough to issue this whole
raid on his house and you saw today the
fbi saying we don't like the word raid
stop using raids so then you saw msnbc
go in real time and change the word raid
to a oh a routine search warrant and so
if it's all that it was it's just some
boxes got left behind like they just
made the case for trump 2024 which says
to me i mean i believe they know that
yeah that going after a sitting
president is a very very serious matter
so they
really wanted whatever those documents
were
again look
when it comes to conspiracy theories
they're fun i'd love to believe in a
world where trump is behind the scenes
and he's like walking down the hallway
and they're like mr former president we
have the plan we have the the documents
here and he's like they don't know who
they're up against
but in reality it's like some intern
grabbed a box and he's just like what
are they searching for they're in my
safe and then they find a box and it's
like just routine confidential nonsense
is trump the mastermind everybody wants
to be is there a deep underground is
there a cabal is there a secret
conspiracy are the elites at war uh i
don't think he's a mastermind but i do
think you you nailed it earlier when you
were talking about some of the agencies
in the deep state that he's his
presidency exposed like how big that rot
was so i think trump's a guy more than
anything that's just honest and pretty
bombastic in nature and so he came in
and he's going with his playbook and
there are a lot of people in the way of
that playbook and i don't think it was
because of his genius 4d chess i think
he was just being different than any
president we've ever had and in turn it
blew up a lot of the
china that was in the oval office and in
the bureaucratic establishment of dc and
then all of a sudden we're realizing
that like whoa the mess is way deeper
than we realized and so we credit that
to trump but trump's just being who he
is trump just came in like a bull in a
china shop and knocked everything over
and in turn we're learning like whoa
this is this stench is rotten i think
you know what i've said in the past
about trump is that he slips on a banana
peel but pulls a perfect backflip yes
like you watch
like the ukraine gate yeah the phone
call he had with uh with uh
i think it was lindsay yeah was was
funny because he was like what's this
thing we're hearing about joe biden and
the prosecutor i don't know could you
look into that and it was like they
tried painting trump as this nefarious
like 4d chess mastermind who was
orchestrating sabotaging joe biden's
candidacy when reality the reality was
he was on twitter and he saw a video
someone retweeted of biden saying if you
don't fire the prosecutor you don't get
the billion dollars and trump's like oh
i better call this guy and ask him he's
like what is that and so they're like
he's a mastermind trying to sabotage
biden
uh he probably slept in a banana banana
peel but it worked yeah it worked now we
all know about it so more forrest gump
than adolf hitler is what you're saying
yeah yeah
and it works out because i actually you
know
people believe what they want about
trump that's fine i my big thing is that
i believe he means what he says um
especially related to his motivations
around things honestly he's pretty
forward about his own self-interest in a
lot of dealings but his self-interest
ends up helping the american people a
lot of ways this was his campaign in
2016 as like this pro-america
nationalist sort of mentality around
things like manufacturing and the
economy in general like that resonated
with american people because by being
himself in turn it was really fighting
for the interest that americans finally
felt like were represented by a
political candidate
and i i just
you know i'm i'm i'm chilling
things may be bad the night is always
darker for the dawn but from 2016 to now
when you think about how the
establishment lost control it's kind of
funny yeah yeah yeah the shot and freud
of their failures is oh yeah he gave me
a psychic jolt of like the um you as an
american can take care of yourself and
your your immediate reality but it also
i've started to think about the military
industrial complex and i used to be very
hateful of it and critical of it but now
i'm like there's gonna be one on earth
there's going to be an overarching
military is it going to be one that the
u.s controls or is it going to be one
that china controls i i want to i want
to make sure i issue a clarification
because it may have sound as if we were
saying he does have class of information
i don't know that yeah that's just the
accusation
people people are claiming
that the feds did seize the documents
they were looking for i don't know if
that's kind of i saw these tweets where
they're like well if they went in there
that means they had to have gotten a
warrant which means he was must have
been committing a crime i'm like what in
the hell kind of yeah reverse logic what
did you do well they don't believe in
the fifth innocent until proven guilty
and i just because they say they found
something doesn't mean they found
something we gotta you know you really
need evidence here we gotta display
evidence i don't like the patriot act i
don't like that people can can detain
people without recourse this is insane
are you even trying to understand the
banality of evilly
these are people who are who are
cheering for the idea that guilty until
proven innocent
well i don't hear innocent people
getting raided by the fbi so clearly it
must mean trump's guilty if you have
nothing to hide then let them spy on you
like no that's not how it works man you
have the right to privacy yeah and i
tweeted something the other day about
the irs and how these 87 000 agents are
coming and are going to make your life
worse and every conceivable way and
someone said well you shouldn't be
worried if you don't have anything to
hide and i'm like so i should be fine
with surveillance because i don't have
anything to hide that's the exact same
argument like what about your balls yeah
right like if you're putting cameras
everywhere maybe you don't want people
looking at your body and also what if
they pass some new law where it's like
it's illegal to be a human and then
they're like you're like or it's illegal
to walk outside on two like you can't
make a stupid law and then yeah uh spy
on someone to see if they're violating
your stupid law and then bust them for
that yeah just because your conscience
is clean and you're not doing anything
wrong doesn't mean you should have your
house broken into especially when you're
the former president of the united
states with all the political
implications that come with that and
then even this representative from
pennsylvania like he just said what
happened agents walked up took his phone
they could have gone through the lawyers
there would have been a cordial process
but it was that nope you know what we
believe you're guilty already and we're
just gonna yank they want to make sure
he didn't delete anything off this phone
but like they gave hillary clinton
plenty of time to schedule emails she
had her phone smashed with hammers yeah
of course she was working with the dnc
and the democratic establishment i don't
like calling i don't want to play
democrat republican here she's with that
liberal economic order um and i don't
think this guy was
fair point is that trump has not been
charged with anything and they did take
hillary clinton's server and and and
scan through it and read every email
so
yeah i saw some pretty damning stuff
come out of her emails oh yeah oh i mean
there was a hundred i mean well for one
the wikileaks stuff yeah dc cc and
things like that but uh she had 110
classified emails so
people are pointing out now like yeah
well they did it to hillary and she
didn't get charged with the crime and
trump's not being charged with the crime
and it's like yes we understand there's
a double standard
yeah they're they're not going to come
out and be like well trump did it but so
did hillary no they're going to be like
trump did it lock him up
i'm getting the feeling people are like
starting to accept that it's like uh
just okay maybe the government is kind
of dirty and evil and they got a side
that they want you to be on but i just
want to be on that side then let's just
keep doing our life let's keep having
sunday cookouts and eating watermelon
and life's going to be dandelions but
like at some point you got to stand up
for righteousness itself and and like
not just be in a club i don't know man
maybe that's not true maybe it's like
pick your tribe and that's how it's
always been
i don't know i yeah no i i don't know
how you would go to sleep at night if i
knew what was right and i don't do it
it's that exact thing i'm denying
righteousness i'm denying the
opportunity to make change i think
people have lost the hope that they can
make change which is a deeper issue
because i think they feel like okay well
the establishment's in place and clearly
it's not moving if they're willing to go
after the former president like they can
destroy my life i think there's a level
of hopelessness but my big encouragement
to people all the time is like that
happened over the course of a few
decades it can be reversed over the
course of a few decades as well like all
you need is someone to come in into
different positions of power in regions
around the country that basically strip
everything out one thing that i'm
excited about that i was disappointed in
trump even going back to this
conversation in 2016 is he had all these
hopes of draining the swamp he gets in
he refuses to fire a lot of people that
made the problems really really bad his
worst mistake was that he had personnel
around him that was really detrimental
now i think if it was to be him or
anyone in 2024 you're right ian
everything is so out in the open that
it's like you can't deny it anymore you
have to uproot or else we're not going
to make it moving forward this is why
they they won't allow a power change
exactly this is this is the democratic
establishment the democrats and many
conservatives
rejecting the peaceful transition of
power but they're doing it early
it's funny because there's viral tweets
jack bosovic retweeted one guy who's who
was criticizing trump over a ukraine
gate saying he was going after his
political rival
and it's like all right where are you
now
yeah because what's what's the
difference yeah if that was your
argument yeah
joe biden didn't announce he was running
for president no one thought he was
gonna yeah they didn't think he's a
frontrunner and the funny thing is many
progressives who are bernie progressives
were telling me like he's clearly going
after biden i'm like aren't you a bernie
supporter like what makes you think
biden is the front runner why why
wouldn't trump be going after bernie he
was the guy everyone was talking about
they're like oh wow
you know in regards to what you're
saying michael about winding it back
like it took us 20 years from the
patriot act to get to this crazy
surveillance state that we could wind it
back i don't know if that's true because
the digital data is there to be scraped
and it's like we have to
go forward and create like um encryption
like levels of quantum encryption that
even government agencies and and
military complex machines can't hack if
that's possible um
and it's like
there's no it's like an avalanche and
we're not gonna make the avalanche go
back uphill you just gotta figure out
how to build a suit so that you can swim
the avalanche and not get crushed by the
snow what does reversing course mean for
individuals anyway
in what in what context
in this transfer of power well because
we complied with it for two decades
like we we've done the things we've
danced the dance we've done what they've
told us to we bought the stuff from
china we sacrificed our convictions and
what made america special on the altars
of cheap convenience we did the things
so that we could have levels of
ease and convenience in the marketplace
and our travel experience and et cetera
and i think part of reverting course in
my mind looks like the average american
standing up and just detaching from that
system anymore saying i'm not going to
keep going along with it and so we saw a
lot of that happen in the past year with
kovid and the whole vaccine mandate
stuff is you had people finally get
pushed to a brink where they said like
my job's on the line but i don't care my
convictions are so strong that i'll let
them fire me
and they'll take away the demand and
then you see companies start to revert
course because of that i think that's
how we do it for a lot of people it
wasn't just about convictions it was
just a stress test yeah some people were
like i'm just done i'd rather sleep
under a bench i'd rather just
sleep in the street than deal with all
of this stuff thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 p.m and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you